[Music]
you guys it's been a crazy week in
america
let's find out what happened
former vice president joe biden has been
elected the next
president of the united states the race
was called six days ago and that's the
first time i've said that without
banging a pot
that's right joe biden was declared the
winner of the 2020 election on saturday
and i didn't think i'd be so excited but
here's me on a normal day
and here's me one hour after biden was
declared the winner
that's a real video i do not know that
man
and i do not remember what happened next
but that is a hangover
i will never forget i i got an email
saying
who took this video i had to be like oh
no
i don't know where it came from i don't
know i took it
president trump played golf on saturday
and this is crazy
biden won that too president trump's
campaign held
a press conference on saturday at four
seasons
total landscaping next to an adult
bookstore
an adult bookstore or as trump calls it
a library
hey president trump's campaign held a
press conference on saturday at the four
seasons total
landscaping because what better way to
end a campaign than at a place that
literally spreads manure
trump's campaign held a press conference
on saturday at four seasons total
landscaping
four seasons that's four more seasons
than trump has
left as president
senator kamala harris was elected vice
president on saturday
and though the economy is not quite back
on track the airbrush
t-shirt industry is thriving
remember all those aaliyah airbrush
t-shirts my god
go to crossroads mall in omaha nebraska
1990 whatever and that's all there was
do you want an elia t-shirt or you were
the coolest if you could airbrush
i know whose parents could afford that i
don't know
brianna you're like oh god she's got
some good clothes
uh one number the t-shirt wasn't paint
on it the
cdc recently recommended that people
bring their own food to thanksgiving
gatherings this year
and as a black woman who married into a
white family
i'm way ahead of you
the creator i can't cook what are these
yams
i have never they're candied
i'm the worst cook in the world and my
husband's like yum yum yum yum
any black person would be like get this
[ __ ]
the creator of the sitcom full house
recently sold the san francisco home
scene on the show for over
5 million dollars when asked what they
plan to do with it the people who bought
it said
burn it down
and finally actress ellen pompeo turned
51 this week
and sandra oh sent her a cake
and if you like grey's anatomy
you like that joke and if you don't like
grey's anatomy
you're you're almost everyone in the
world and
that was the monologue tarik did you
like the monologue
i did i can't trust you you like
everything
look at this tarik did you like the
finale of game of thrones
i did see everything in other news
pharmaceutical company pfizer announced
this week that
the coronavirus vaccine they're
developing
has a 90 effectiveness rate
and some experts say the vaccine could
be ready for distribution
by the end of the year i'm not taking it
what i'm not taking it they can roll out
that vaccine whenever they want i'm not
taking it you don't want to be
vaccinated against the coronavirus
and give up pandemic life no way
terrig pandemic life is terrible
pandemic life
is great i don't have to get hugs from
people i don't know i don't have to
shake hands with anyone who just sneezed
i can turn down literally any social
invitation and people are like oh cool i
get it
i never have to worry about my breath
because i'm wearing a mask and i never
ever have to ride the subway wait how
did you get here
i walked you live in brooklyn i started
three days ago
what else do i have going on and the
best part is
i'm literally always in pajamas
derek you're wearing a suit yeah but
under the suit
on my pajamas oh wow
so you're oh beautiful so you're never
gonna get the vaccine
nope and nothing can change your mind no
way
okay officials are also reporting that
10 new horror movies will be released in
theaters next year okay give me that
vaccine i thought so well played
well the vaccine news is great but not
even that can distract me from last
weekend's
election results we did it joe biden won
and it is time to celebrate last week
was time to celebrate now the real work
begins
already yes we can't just enjoy the fact
that biden won for
just a little bit longer no let's get to
work now
unlike the trump administration the
biden administration is going to face an
uphill battle and i know everything's
not fixed but
we defeated a real-life monster so
please
let me have this let me enjoy victory
let me have this frigging black lady vp
started with a few votes then they got a
few more
begins with a rumble and it ends with a
roar
let me have this let me have this
let me have this
[Music]
madam vice president it has such a nice
ring to it
let me have this later we'll take folks
to task
let me have this let's enjoy we kicked
ass
no more of the bad guy or his little
crap kids
i never lost faith in us except when i
did
let me have this let me have this
let me have this people are gonna be
like
oh my god do you remember the last
president who and i'll be like now
let me have this i don't care that
donald will sue
let me have this and give doubt a big
iou
i know feeling hopeful can be kind of
odd
but look at what stacy abrams did oh my
god
let me have this gotta let me have this
let me have this
[Music]
let me have this and
we have to have to win the georgia
runoffs like we have to those are two
senate seats they're huge
ah i'm sorry amber i i rambled on and
anyway you want to get the show started
in a minute we'll be right back with
more of the amber ruffin show
[Music]
you